e
here on this uh for the public uh this
is the uh oversight committee
responsible The Joint oversight
committee responsible for the
Improvement and assessment we're dealing
with the Ed 306 rules uh we met last
week and we're continuing to meet today
we've met numerous times I can count the
number of times we've met dealing with
306 is either by this committee or
another and what we want to do is uh
look through these write down some of
our our
recommendations uh and pass those
recommendations on to Jael car and to uh
the Department of
Education so with that uh I have handed
out to the committee here a sheet which
I did yesterday try to capsulize some of
the uh areas that I've spoken to
regarding the 306s and then if you look
at the top of the sheet you can see
where it says page number so I used
reference back to the 991224 conditional
approval of
the of the um uh Department of State
Board of Education the Ed rule number
whether it be 306.000 2 or whatever uh
going on down through and the change
rationale is it statutory or is it
policy at n stands for statutory change
reference
P would be a policy um reference or
recommendation and jel car just remind
jel car cannot deal with policy they
deal with the
statute and and so that we as a
committee that is a policy committee can
deal with the areas of policy as well
and make those recommendations to the
state board and then on the uh rightand
side of that you can see in that column
uh uh comments that support are the
proposed um change does do people back
there have copies of this uh I do have
some extras right here so why don't you
there let me know if there's not enough
there because I do have an extra copy
here uh represent Pell said she would be
here a little late and Ruth Ward Senator
Ward had a meeting going on in uh maybe
here
so with that we need to try to get
something down and and express our uh
responses to any areas of the 306 rules
and so that we can communicate with
others on Jael car and others on the
State Board of
Education
so if we walk through these rules from
the start to front front half to the
back half as we've done so many times
but we should have already starred
certain areas where there are concerns
that's what I've done with this right
here
so as a starting point I'll mention the
first one I have and then we can walk
continue to walk seeing the first one is
one of those definitions which is how
right the front side of the
306s and the definition has to do with
which I I believe has uh references
later on when we talk about other
aspects of the
three6 the definition of educator as I
see it is that it's a statutory
definition and the definition which we
have
here let's see let me get
my first
half I referenced it back to page two
two of the conditional
approval and the conditional approval on
page two identifies educator means
administrators educational Specialists
instructional Specialists teachers par
Educators educator interpreter and trans
literate
literator I never had Trans literator in
a school I don't know what that
yeah okay a translator okay and School
nurses and any other individuals
credentialed by the state
board uh the statutory reference that
I'm looking at is RSA 21 n8-
DC and we talked about and that means a
teacher or certified par par
professional period then there's another
reference in RSA 18914 a Roman
5 that means any professional employee
of any school district whose position
requires certification as a professional
engaged in
teaching the term teacher shall also
include principes Librarians and
guidance counselors so that's also in
statutory
law so my my uh rationale or suggestion
is that the definition that's in the
306s reflects
statutory
lock K we have two two sheets I handed
out we're looking at the one that's got
the columns on it underneath that one
yeah right we just started thank you
you're
welcome so let's open up the comments on
question sure sure Mr chair I I agree
with that um that um that tightening up
on that definition to reflect um
statutory language makes a lot of sense
and I think one of the concerns I had
following the uh commissioner's
testimony last week was um was when the
term educator I think was being used in
the context of the um the the student
teacher uh ratios where uh where the
commissioner said um said oh no only
Educators that were certified to teach
those classes would be used in the
calculation of the ratios but the
language in the proposed rules doesn't
doesn't provide for that limitation so
um so if if there is going to be a
limitation that's intended there as the
commissioner spoke to I think that
limitation should be articulated
specifically in the rules thank you and
you notice on the second page of the
sheet I handed out to you at the base on
page 12 the conditional report it speaks
to student educator ratios and there's a
lot of rationale for are saying
teacher um uh or educator ratios based
upon the
definition um my perspective is that the
the ratio we use for classrooms is not
does not involve
just the teacher that's assigned that
classroom there's other Educators that
come in and make up that ratio as was
defined back in 2007 and 2008
uh in the uh oversight
committee uh for the uh costing of an
adequate education and we'll get into
that um so let's stick with the top part
first and get down to the student
teacher ratio when we get that location
so um back to the first definition here
the we've looked at other definitions
which we've communicated with the
department and they they've Bas they've
come out agreed that definition should
reflect statutory
language so is there any problem with us
moving forward with a recommendation of
both gelar and to the department that
the term educator reflect 21 in da da da
da or and possibly the 18914 AV Roman 5
but 21 n8- d parentheses C specifically
says and means a teacher or certified
par professional
okay let's march on then so is that the
21n definition or was that the other one
that's the 21n definition the other one
too speaks to and it goes further which
I think is very very important means any
professional employee of any school
district whose position requires
certification as a professional engaged
in
teaching the term teacher also shall
also include principes Librarians and
guidance counselors there's another
place in the statutes where the guidance
counsel has been left out and so this
now if we reference that that statutory
language as well it means that the
guidance counselor has to have you know
be certified as well well so what's
what's currently being used then in the
calculation of the student teacher ratio
is it the 21n definition or is it the
18939 is it 189 what what did you say it
was I I think what's referencing that
ratio our our rules no no no it's not
even mentioned within statute okay no my
my my point is our um are our certified
professionals such as library media
Specialists and principles currently
being used in the calculation of student
teacher ratios because I think the no no
ratios this is a you got to look at that
second set of paperwork that I gave you
um which talks about the student to
Personnel ratios which is you'll find
that and the report for costing of a
public education put out by that
committee back in 2007 and
8 and in that they have a number of
ratios make up the total Personnel
ratios and this is used right now in the
calculation of Base cost in our adequacy
formula and so you have the student
teacher
ratio specialty teachers you know
there's like teachers come in for about
20% of that time as as during teacher
preps music PE M library art um
depending upon the individual School how
they do it and so that's in that
calculation as specialist teachers
specialty teachers then others that come
in is the principal ratio that's based
upon number of students in the school
and administrative assistant ratio
library media specialist ra ratio so you
see there's where the that is technology
uh ratio uh custodian ratio and and
deals with Personnel not included and it
the formula goes on and mentions things
like equipment is all yeah so I so I
think this is where um where obviously
it it gets
used in in different in different ways
whether it's being used to calculate the
um the um uh cost of inadequate
education there is a a ratio used there
I think that tends to be more of a
class-size number as opposed to a
District student teacher ratio and then
when the commissioner was here last week
he talked about a um a student teacher
ratio that I think probably included
library media Specialists and principles
and other credential things uh
credential positions that to a ratio of
and I forgot what he said but it was
around um uh 12:1 or 12.7 to1 it was
something like that and so so so I I
think if we're going to uh be using that
12.7 or whatever it is in some elements
and then a 25 to one in some other
things that we need to uh just make sure
what that that the you know how that
diff definition is is
um I I don't know maybe it's not maybe
it's two different definitions for two
different um ratio uses of ratios or
numbers U because I you know we don't we
certainly don't use 12.7 to1 in the cost
I mean I'm seeing nods because I I think
I'm what I'm saying is correct I think
we we don't use it in the cost of
inadequate
education um calculation
yeah we we've used that student to
Personnel ratios and underneath that the
student teacher ratio in regard to the
classes yeah oh you know and that's
stated under student teacher ratio it
talks about 25 to1 K through 2 it talks
about the 30 to1 for the other levels it
talks about the um uh uh what's see um
to meet the school approval standards
are 25 to1 in kindergarten through grade
two and third yeah yeah and and I
misspoke it's not the cost ofac it's the
base cost calculation isn't that yeah
but see the the all these ratios go
together to make the universal yeah cost
M which is which becomes our base cost
that's where it's coming from from the
inputs the the the the 31 30 to1 25 to1
those numbers that that that's those
what contribute to the F how the base
cost is figured out right but that's a
different those rely on a different
definition of educator than the than the
definition that gets you to the 12.7 to
one well they rely upon that student
teacher ratio that's in that costing
report that's what they do there then
the specialty teachers and all that come
on to that
formula uh this was driven by that group
that put it together years and years ago
and it hasn't been touched since we have
changed base cost but we've never really
reflected That Base cost in terms of the
we haven't changed that K through 2 or
three grades 3 through 12 and there's
been discussion of it there was
discussion on on on the Karen umberger
report I can recall uh when I brought up
the recommendation to reduce it to 20 to
one and they that's not where we're
going in this committee so that stopped
right there um there was even thoughts
of of of when we were looking at last
year when I was looking at and trying to
work with the the research people
upstairs of recognizing the elementary
education was K through two I was taking
and I was staying with a statory if you
ask me what elementary education is it
goes a lot higher than you know right up
about grade six or five um the middle
school is come in there but I would
suggest that it go k through three and
grades four
through 8 are the middle school grades
identified in
statute represent Celli uh thank you um
getting back to uh M on the proposed
rules where it has the definition for
educator um I think uh what we need to
do here is tie it to statute as was
indicated um if you look at the
definition for curriculum it just says
as defined in RSA Etc
so don't we here just have to say
educator um uh means as defined in RSA
218 a d Etc and if we want to change the
educator definition we change it in 21
and
8 okay so you're saying
to do it the definition would be
pursuant to the the yeah the 21 and8
yeah
definition and if we need and if we want
to change the definition of educator we
and8 why would we not also reference
areas which is um on your sheet yeah
number two yeah correct yes
yeah yeah we can do that requires
certification I'm primarily concerned
that in the classroom the classroom
teacher now it's you can have people
that come in see then we have the issue
well we dealt with on the committee of
conference last year with the uh people
coming out of the University system to
teach at
Franklin that were paid by Franklin but
they came in and they didn't have
teacher certification they had some of
them had phds in education they were
coming in and doing the Dual concurrent
enrollment so that b Bill basically said
that they're
authorized it wasn't dealing with
certification this is a is this a big
area here we're dealing with and I think
that before we try to delve down into
some of the policy issues we make a
reference directly to a
statute that's what Jael car's going to
have to do they can't change policy and
those are the issues that we need to
address as policy
people we got there's a lot of
definitions and lot of this whole
work
um go ah so so yeah Mr chair I was just
trying to pull up the digital version of
the of the front and back half side by
sides um to do a quick search on where
the word where the term I don't want to
say word where the defined term educator
is being used in the um in the proposed
rules because um how how you define that
is going to affect obviously the ratios
but
also a lot of
other yeah see initially when I was
looking at this when I was looking at
the
ratios I had the word class in there too
class pupil teacher ratios but then
that's you know that's it's it's a
bigger issue than that there's other
Personnel that come in are involved that
are certified staff that it's not just
your classroom teacher it's other
well and I I you know to deal with this
I think we really need to have to look
back back at this report which was done
by Senator estherbrook and Senator
Styles and senator now it was
representative Carson back then and
um Emma Rouse representative Rouse I
can't remember who else was on that but
those were the people that were on that
um Mary Heath was involved with some of
this back when she was assistant
time so
we can we can talk this forever but I
think what we got to do is just say for
right now and then we may make some
recommendations ourselves for where we
need to go with some of this is that we
statute everybody good with that MH and
we'll get into discussion ratios at the
next when we get down to that right
right my only my only you know point
there is that is that when when looking
at the the definition of educator it it
affects other things in the um in the in
the proposed rules and ratios being one
of them uh but um um but there there may
be others as well and you know I just
noticed one one section that that says
educator or other staff so so that
that's even a a you know a broader use
of of um and this was under INR the
current definition of instructional time
so so I just want to be conscious of
that as we move through this that's a
big definitional change thanks so going
down through are there any other
definitions that I I I mentioned one
opportunities and and why I did that
because it's both statutory but it's
um in the current rule references
acquisition of Knowledge and Skills
through instruction or study outside the
traditional classroom that goes
on current rule is based upon exact
statatory language taken from RSA 193
col
one uh see that's Roman
1h1 and which says these plans may
include but are not limited to such
components or combination of components
of extended uh uh components of Extended
Learning opportunities as independent
study private instruction performing
groups internships community service
apprenticeships and online
courses should the new rule again
reference those policy statements which
are statutory too it's in in writing or
should we just leave it where the El L's
elos so the way that they've got here in
us in the in the uh proposal they have
means a personalized learning process
that allows for achievement of compeny
that that's awfully vague don't you
classroom well we have you know it a lot
of times the classroom the classroom now
is larger just than the brick and mortar
uh it goes into community service some
high schools require community
service um they have Capstone projects
um the online um teaching now is
extremely important internship programs
are done in conjunction with the teacher
in the school that's teaching
mathematics
maybe um so yes I I think that uh uh
elos at the district level uh can vary
from District to District in terms of
what they um will uh offer as ELO
opportunities so I I'm fine with it in
the proposed rules um and then we get
into learning opportunities um which
page any other points on that I I think
the elos can go can occur inside and
outside of the
classroom you know in or a school or
within a district
is that out if you if you're doing
something
outside your classroom or your school
and doing it elsewhere let's say in the
curriculum office at the
district is
classroom fruit for thought
so Ju Just Another thought on um on on
elos when um when when what's being
proposed is you know
replacing this exemplary
list in the existing rules independent
studies private instruction on because
it says including but not limited to so
these are examples yeah and now the in
the proposed rule the only example is
means a personalized learning process
that's right it's taken all the the such
as or not you know not limited to right
right but but the for example helps I
mean it gives it gives people I think a
structure uh behind what that definition
I mean um as opposed to no structure
behind the definition and um uh I mean
it's not ruling out things outside of
these seven areas but uh personalized
learning
process you know I think like what what
what what Patty was what representative
Cornell was suggesting is
yeah I have no idea I have no objection
to adding uh the list under uh including
to did you all look at the um reference
93 colon one
uh it goes down to Roman
1H and then one where it says these
plans may include but are not limited to
such components or a combination of
components of Extended Learning
opportunities as independent study
Etc that's the part that I thought was
helpful so that's 1931
H not 193 one colon one yeah is that a
one or is that Roman one that's Ro it's
a one yeah Roman
one H number
one yeah so there again we would say
pursuant to or as defined in yeah
yeah I don't know why it's going the
other way and taking some of the
suggested oh maybe it's superus I don't
know but it's what's in statute right
once again I go back to something that's
in statute should it should reflect what
statute is in instead of changing it in
the
rule and that's going to save work down
the road in terms of rule making and gel
car and everything else that's
right so on that when I handed out to
you I think
the the rationale for the change is
and it's up it it helps with the policy
as well
so so when so
one R
H1 refers to these seven things what
does it refer to in the language leading
up to that
list well it's underneath the compulsory
attendance for by pup right right but
does it essentially follow what's in the
current rule um I Extended Learning
means the primary acquisition Knowledge
adopting see ex if you look at the way
it's in the the book right now MH it
says Extended Learning means the primary
acquisition of Knowledge and Skills
through instruction or study outside the
traditional classroom
methodology including but not limited to
independent study private instruction
performing groups internships community
service apprenticeships and online
now and
so I I I feel comfortable the way it's
written in statute right now yes statute
or in rule in Rule and Statute in in
current rule in current Rule and statute
it's aligns more like with this that's
306 yeah
um yeah I was
just I I agree with that are we all on
the same page on this just to reflect
again statutory language m yes it
maintains consistency what we're doing
throughout this so we would be
recommending to
revise o in in the proposed rules to be
what I in the current rules yeah which
follows in St yeah
yeah but don't we want to refer to the
statute as well yes yeah yeah right yeah
yeah yeah we could re you know
yeah pursuant too right yeah yeah yeah
basically just adding on to what's
currently in I pursuant to 193 one yeah
okay okay going down through the we're
still in
definitions the other area which I had a
concern
um and this is kind of a picky one too
but um our reference to again 193e con
one Roman 2 school districts then have
responsibility and flexibility and
implementing diverse educational
approaches to instruction and curriculum
tailor to meet student
needs um and I also
mention uh RSA 189 colon 1- a rment to
duty provide
education um instructional time means
the period of time during which
instructions offered which is a function
of school schedule classroom management
and local school board approved
curriculum I I've written a lot into
that I'm not hung up on this as
much but it's some you know I
instructional time there's been efforts
in the past to say to schools X Y and Z
you will teach
social studies 60 minutes per week in
the grade
school
and and then some are saying well I
teach that in conjunction with my
reading I teach this in conjunction with
that or I want to teach 90 minutes per
week um and and and that's what our
curriculum directs instruction directs
are do in this school I think that we're
getting into some dangerous area when we
start to identify specific number of
minutes and I don't think they're doing
it in
this
proposal I don't have any problem
leaving it General as in yeah as
got instruction means you know that's
one so so Ju Just for example um if um
if a student was was doing a
reading
um you know free reading inside of a
English class would that be considered
instructional time under the current
definition and would it be considered
definition somebody else barking on that
yeah and the the only reason I'm asking
because the under the current definition
it's it's um working towards achieving
educational objectives which I think
reading could be you know you know could
be doing that whereas under the new
definitions period of time which
and I I just don't know the answer to to
that
so is recess and the grade school
instructional
time can anybody out there answer that
question to me is recess period for a
grade two grade three
student recess I believe it
is it's not typically done in the
classroom but there's instruction going
on is
supervised often times maybe not even by
a teacher it might be a pair of
professional out there or maybe somebody
that's hired to take care of recess
duties that's the other stuff pardon me
I wouldn't call that
instruction not well but under the under
the current definition though under the
current
definition means the period of time
during which pups are actively working
toward achieving educational objectives
under the supervision of an educator or
other staff member that might be
instruction I I don't know the answer
but maybe that qualifies for first grade
I I've seen the in the lower grades that
that counts as instructional time recess
does if we expanded uh or we changed
kindergarten so we have play based
instruction
so so that I think that fits in the
well so
so
[Music]
you
yeah can they can you can other words is
this being recorded yeah we're being
then nobody could
hear
chrisa if you want to come up and read
that again in front of the mic yeah we
so red red light on light all right
there Christina pretorius a policy
director with reaching higher New
Hampshire um the current uh rules do say
that elementary schools May count up to
30 minutes of recess per day as
instruction time for pupils in
yeah yeah
so so would that be considered
instructional time under the proposed
yeah means the period of time during
is so I let me ask you different is
there anything that that would qualify
as instructional time under the current
definition that would not qualify as
instructional time under the new
definition or vice
versa No actually they're not changing
that definition they're proposing is
it's the proposal that's currently in
rule no yeah my oh excuse me I'm I'm
looking at the wrong book here yeah
objectives that could be just about
school kindergarten socialization
they're learning how to behave with each
other learning how to respect
rules according to what we just heard
about recess time I would think the
proposed um rule uh fits uh encompasses
that better than the current
rule
MH yeah but in the under the new
proposal instruction time means the
period of time which instruction is
offered um now take that phrase
instruction and is offered and plug in
the definition of instruction from right
above means deliberate and strategic
approaches to facilitate student
learning I I don't know if that's
instruction if facilitating student
learning
is it's do we have a current definition
so so I I I guess what I'm trying to get
at is in the current definition of
instructional time talks about the
period of time during which pupils are
actively working towards achieving
educational objectives under the
supervision of an educator or other
staff
member so that would I I guess means the
period of time and then basically all
the words in the current
definition I guess are defining what
instruction
means pupils are actively working
towards achieving educational objectives
under the supervision of an educator or
other staff member that appears to be
the what what the definition of
instruction is in the current rules in
the proposed rules the def definition of
instruction
changes to being instruction means
deliberate and strategic approaches so
it's an approach to F to facilitate
um instruction is an approach that's the
instruction well that's also reflected
in statute of 193 E1 Roman 2
where say school districts then have
responsibility and flexibility in
implementing diverse educational
approaches to instruction approaches to
instruction but that's
not and tailored to meet student
needs other words instruction policies
is School Board
responsibility right right but I think
rather than an approach to do
instruction it's now saying instruction
is an approach it's it's just turn
around I
I yeah what what what I mean what does
it mean to you Mr chair well it it it
caught my attention that's why I wrote
this down as there there's a question on
this I I've always gotten concerned
when the state gets in the
business of trying to tell us here's
your instructional time I guess I'm a
local control guy that believes that my
high school issues the the diploma based
upon our curriculum and our instruction
conforming with this academic standards
or the old carige unit numbers and all
that but uh I I I I really concern that
we don't get in the point where
we're I think the state has
responsibility to ensure that when
you're at school 5 hours and a half 5
hours 75 whatever it might be that is
on however you know that there's some
kids that are in high school that
maybe only taking three courses or three
credits or three whatever that and the
other two it's a five block schedule may
be done with a study hall or
some offline type online type program
and that that that could be an ELO that
could be that could be an independent
study yeah anything right right and so
um so that would all be I think we need
flexibility and that was what's in
statute there in
193e it has to maintain re flexibility
in
implementing you know but does that have
to be in rules also no it's in statute
right
right but are you saying then that the
flexibility I think we're getting down
if we propose something to Jael car
we're going to have to really say Okay
Jael car
it's it's a statutory issue
policy is they're not interested in
that so how do how does the stat how
does the statute um treat instructional
time
the
189 one Roman 2 does not speak
specifically to educational time it just
says that the school board
is is responsible for establishing
structure accountability advocacy and
delivery of instruction in each School
okay
so all I did with the suggestion on the
bottom of the sheet that I have I have
the the recommendation that's being put
forth by the state board instruct time
means the period of time during which
instruction is offered then I add in
which is a function of school schedule
classroom management and local school
board approved
curriculum that was all
my thoughts it's not based on any kind
of
Statute I
I I think that would work yeah I don't
that of adding that latter part or just
correct so that would be we're
suggesting to the department then this
policy added to their
definition could you repeat that it's on
the bottom of page one on the right hand
side there representative Cornell where
you see a parentheses at the very bottom
in the right hand column instructional
time means the period of time during
which instruction is offered that's what
the state board's recommending there the
which
is or that is a function of school
schedule classroom management and local
school board approved
curriculum it's a reflection of a lot of
things
well what so one of the one of the
um it's a little bit of a stretch but
well not really the the um the term
instruction in the current rules
reflects under the supervision of an
member but that would not apply to an
ELO
necessarily well it it it does because
you I think even in an ELO you you
generally have like your school to
Career coordinator that's overseeing the
uh the ELO even though they may not be
ELO event
maybe we're going too far with this
maybe what the stateboard has stopping
at offered and not getting into the wise
who's because I put down a couple
rationale but then you're bringing up
another one you know and and who's
responsible for providing that
instruction well the classroom teacher
or the certified teacher
or it maybe not it it may be a pair of
professional underneath the supervision
of a certified teacher or it maybe a
certified
pair those are all other staff members
yeah yeah I agree well could be a
contracted service too yeah Speech
Pathology yeah yeah yeah other staff M
so so should we just leave it the way
they had
it I think so okay let's just leave it
that now are there any other areas
within definitions
we want to make note of or recommend
not we could jump to the next one I had
but you know I'm jumping to another page
page six
from page two there's 3 four five in
okay if if we want to go to the the
policy development portion it's under
basic learning standards
including it goes into the homework
digital
literacy all
had suggest here
that uh a five number five be put in
there when we're talking how students
can pursue various learning
opportunities including we have virtual
learning let's see the virtual learning
academy career related credentials and
certification I put down Career
Technical education courses and programs
and then I also put in there math
learning communities pursuant to RSA 193
-
one those are some programs which we put
in place that since the old rules were
put in
place the math learning communities we
funded this year there's been an a
program at nhti bringing in over 38 40
Math teachers from across the
state they're implementing the the math
high school
programs C education courses and
programs have significantly changed
things we also have separate rules for
the
CCH but should they be referenced here
too
if if we are you know not going there
one want to leave that area as it
is okay we'll leave that as is without
having to add on anything meaning as is
proposed
is and going down to the next one which
school
facilities I brought this up at the last
time we
met
um the local school board shall require
that facilities operated by the school
district for K through 12 and I injected
in there the latter part there and for
prek children purum to RSA 190 186 and
RSA 186 C9 those are both in C purposes
education it's not necessarily what I
you know referenced last time nutrition
programs which is also reason
why um facility support
but they've got to be able to support
these children at age three through age
five and we're doing that in every
District now I understand we don't have
prek kindergarten some districts do and
they're doing that on their own
nickel but we don't fund it in the
funding formula we go k through
support ages three through 5 that have a
handicapping condition an
IEP and that's done in the schools in
the
facilities so what what's wrong with the
current definition of
facilities it it says basically K
through 12 no no I'm talking about in
the current
rules the current rules yeah just
that's on page 16 of the side by side on
the side by side so I mean did Ed 320
well n320 is the those the school
buildings right so does ed3 so the the
30607 does not reference Ed
320 the current rule references
is um various building codes and ventil
you know building code requirements and
things like that what does Ed 320
reference uh
the the approval
process
purposes um what has to be
submitted uh maintenance plans
Etc
process so why would the approval
process be in there as opposed to a sort
of a structural requirement um for
school fa you know the local school or
shall you know require the facilities
for each School provide the following
you know lays down the um the hard
requirements for for that as opposed to
the application
process I mean the application Pro you
facility Well it does go into uh air
quality um you know much of just
glancing at it you know what's what's
included in current rule is in in
320 health and safety
inspections
um that's all the stuff that comes
underneath Amy Clark and the engineering
department over there
um my my the reason why I put that here
is that I've said
it is that we do have children that are
younger than
mhm and if I'm following this correctly
it
320 um
o2d I believe it could be um it says a
school facility that meets all of the
applicable application requirements of
Ed 302
3202 shall be approved for operation so
I think that sums it up in that one
sentence the ref the reference back to
rule can you read a l part of that again
please from the rule yeah it's a a a
school facility that meets all of the
applicable application requirements of
Ed
operation yeah it
say in the new proposed rule that says
are approved to operate or are
conditionally approved to operate in
accordance with 8320 and circles back if
I'm not mistaken so we should we leave
it the way they
proposed
y yeah up and down so so no no so I'm
I'm I'm just trying to see what we've
lost here so does 320 talk about
um uh you know lack of specialized
spaces for Arts science technology
education does it talk about that or
does it talk is it a school is it a
facility approval
process does it actually say you have to
have certain spaces to do certain things
or is it an approval process for
facilities cuz a current rule talks
so set said another way Mr chair why are
we changing what why why is the why is
there a proposal to change the current
facilities because isn't most that other
stuff in 320
I'm not looking at I'm looking at
lighting and
at when I looked at it I thought I saw
it is no one from the Department coming
today to answer questions no they were
here I know no I don't think we're going
long certainly addresses uh safety
ventilation
um
Health inspections by the department air
and in the appendix 320
yeah but it doesn't say that um that for
example
um you know uh you know addressing a
lack of of specialized spaces for for
science I just I just looked at the
looked for the um occurrence of the word
science in Ed 320 and it comes in two
places and it just says that if you have
a science lab you need chemical hoods
and I mean it doesn't actually say you
lab emergency shower and eyewash shall
be available in all science
labs but it doesn't say what you need it
just it's a it's a um it's a building
it's a facility approval
process I mean I think we're losing
well I think that the old 306.97 is is
is
stronger and the singular sentence we
Mr chair yeah I think 320 is for initial
um approved but then the 306.97 is the
continuing requirements to keep yeah
going
that's a good
catch but 320 does include renewals as
approvals well the the 320 does deal
with initial approval and all the
conditions which are like fire and
health and safety codes that's all
320 this right here I think represent
Cornell is is on that course is is the
current rule specifies that you got to
address things like Lighting and Sound
Acoustics and you got to look at air
ventilation
um and there's a lot of data out there
saying that schools are current with
that stuff their achievement scores will
so do we want to make a recommendation
3067 maybe with a reference to the 320
to yes
yes with a reference or
I think we have to I don't know if we
have to refer to the 320 cuz that's a
it's already there it's administrative
rule
right are you on that Katie fine okay
I had if we go to the next one does
anybody else have anything
30608 learning and instructional
resources
okay this this the language that I
reference here is the new stuff that we
put in the law this past
year the quium shall present broad
pedagogical approach no that's the
sentence prior to what we put
in called by the minum standards Public
School Pro and acum for each area of the
people good with the learning and
instructional resource the way it
is
no um why why was the um the part about
cataloged and classified according to
practices accepted by the American which
one are you on now I'm I'm right on
30608 and the the A2
a
3068 08 current rule yeah
I mean I I don't know why that was
dropped I mean that seems like a
organizational what if that gets updated
yeah well it would be
Up's actually talking about 2005 yeah
you know what you could probably take
out the reference to 2005 and just um
and that that way it would be updated as
so do you feel comfortable in some other
organization that's not part of the
state of New Hampshire telling
do I I I I'm not so sure about that a
lot of organizations
change uh in the direction they're going
and I have a wife who is a library I
mean we're we're already doing that with
facilities I mean we talk about we talk
about you know National Electric Code
mean so why are we going to be
cataloging in accordance with 2005 data
which you know computers hardly existed
well they they certainly existed they
exist I got you where we are
now
I'm I'd be all right letting that float
with with with updated requirements but
I guess what I'm trying to figure out is
what what do we lose when we lose a I
mean you know all schools are doing it
right now would they would they stop
doing it would we lose some sort of
organization of of how instructional
materials are currently being being um
cataloged and
classified um I you know um I don't know
if there's anybody here that could say
lose instructional resources are you
talking about are you talking about
what's in the media center in the
library or you talking about what's
being used as an instructional
resource which it's so broad
now just writing the Civics curriculum
which is coming from the Historical
Society here in
town
um I Civics and everything
else right yeah so so I mean so I mean
do we know do we I don't know if we have
the answer cataloging what's that isn't
it just cataloging cataloging
classifying so you know how to find
stuff
right um why why wouldn't we want to
requirement um the um New
3068 a um includes not just printed
materials but online materials as well
um you know I was um involved in some
Library
Automation and um we got
um away from some of that um requirement
in terms of new um online cataloges
because of search capabilities for
certain terms and so forth so some of
the old catalog um uh sections were no
I I'd like to know why it was taken out
out well I can understand why A1 2A was
taken up because referencing a very
narrow organiz you know a narrow scope
they the Library Association does not
necessarily have catalog all the
instructional materials that are being
used in a school today a lot of that
comes from
online uh some of it might be Career
Tech stuff which is coming from
industry
um I can understand why you know I I
think it's important that things be
cataloged and classified or I don't know
even that um be provided and that's what
they
have local school should require that
each School provide and available a
developmentally appropriate when as
requested
one yeah I'm good with the
proposed I also support the proposed new
rule yeah I mean I think we're talking
about the library here isn't that what
this section is about I don't know see
that that that if we're just talking a
narrow scope of where we
are and so I'm libraries or media
centers or whatever they're calling them
nowadays it may not even be located in
that building it may be all online sure
well um I I mean I'm just sort of you
know look looking at a couple of the
other references that are in that
actually what one of that's in both
managed through circulation policies and
procedures that are designed to maximize
the use of the
resources so that's in both the proposed
and the original rules and D the prop on
the original rules rules utilize
Community Resources and that could be
the town or city
library they took that out they took
that out and that's been removed so
concern isn't there a school that
doesn't have a library and they go
across the street and use a public
library as their Library so they they no
that I I don't know what situation they
used to have though a certified School
librarian running the public library so
when they're just from here to the other
in the hallway across the street Route
10 yeah and so the kids said Library
class they went over there back and
forth
MH which
is probably the you
know cost effective
yeah yeah if the library is Right town
yeah but we're talking about learn
learning and instructional resources
including online materials and I think
it's um uh really the uh a in the
proposed uh is maybe outdated with
online access to materials and I think
um the uh proposed um really reflects Uh
well it includes not knowing where
technology will go in the next 10 years
before the rules are re
Revisited yeah yeah I mean I'm I'm I I
would be I would be really careful about
um um you know you
know sliding where where Public Library
and school libraries and professional
library media Specialists are when it
comes to the use of new technologies in
their field because I think they're very
well equipped and very well trained in
uh in the incorporation of those those
Technologies as part of instructional
resources so so uh while while while I
I'll certainly admit I'm
not
uh I'm I'm I I don't know what what all
this specifics are behind anglo-american
cataloging rule second edition 2005 uh
maybe there's a newer reference that uh
that goes there or that could be used
there and that is commonly used in
library and and um media
centers but it seems to be that
eliminating it would be um a real step
backward because I think this this is
probably one of the things that that um
that makes Library professional and
makes a library something that that
anybody trained and how to access
materials in libraries like is done
beginning I think in first grade second
grade that that you can walk into any
library and be able to access materials
and I think if there's anything I I mean
I I think this is directly tied with
with with Civics and that if we remove
move this requirement we're we're taking
a major step back so you know for
example if the library at Maple Street
were cataloged according
to I don't know somebody somebody's
local cataloging um design and then you
go to the high school uh which is using
the American Library Association uh
cataloging system you wouldn't be able
to find anything and um or if you moov
to a different School District you
wouldn't be able to find it anything
because you wouldn't have been you
wouldn't have had that experience in
your earlier School uh or then you go to
the town library City library or Library
Congress yeah yeah I mean you're you're
looking at it though
through a scope that's narrowing as the
years go by here in terms
of you read in media which I there was
an article not too long ago in the Wall
Street Journal
how people are reading less books
they're on the web they're doing their
research and everything through
Electronics now and there's fewer people
actually going and taking a book out and
reading
it uh they're turning the TV set on they
forget their information or whatever or
looking at the screen in the computer
and I'm just an antique trying to I I
think that the whole nature of the we
used to say the library media center was
the center of the school in terms of
educational resource
and is it now or is that because the
machine is on Glenn's desk right now is
that the
center of what we've got going on right
now how many people are going to the
library to get a book in fact they're
not ordering those
books they are just some but you know
the it's changed world I think we got to
make is this policy dealing with media
Library centers or is it going Beyond it
talks about circulation and all that
stuff that seems to make me think we're
thinking library but are we now talk
about all the directional resources used
by by the career Tax Center or the the
high school Civics physics class or the
engineering department yeah yeah I know
I I hear what you're think saying but I
think I think these this section is
talking Library just looking at the
language in the original rules and even
in some of the language from the uh from
the proposed rules managed through
circulation processes and procedures
designed to maximize the use of the
resources you say I think this is
Library should we be asking the
department is this SE I think we should
okay so we let's skip over this and get
that answer okay be but but if this is
Li if this is library then I think we
absolutely need to maintain the uh the
standards for libraries if this is
adding on to library then we need to at
least maintain the standards for
existing library and then provide some
you know rational um
um I don't know rules surrounding
surrounding non- library media access
and we've had those discussions around
this see the title for 306.000 is
instructional resources
MH that goes beyond library or is this
if it is going to be media library
Orient oriented do we do we say that in
the the header here maybe that's maybe
it needs to be more clear yeah yeah
that's I think that's a really good
question yeah but in a also you see uh
technologies that shall be necessary to
support
um decades ago I was involved in
automating major university libraries in
the New York area getting rid of card
cataloges there you had you know you're
referring back to the American Library
Association card catalog system Dewey
Decimal System and all that and we went
to online systems where you could put in
Search terms you know you could put in
teacher you didn't have to go to a a
specific uh category um and structures
of categories um in order to find what
you were looking for so I I think that
um you know we're looking at online and
Technologies and you know you know we're
involved in AI these days like it or not
so I I think that um you know the
today and see what we we address
curriculum this last year and what I had
in parentheses there is right out of
statute
the curriculum shall
present and it references then the
minimum standards for public school
approval and the academic standards for
each area of the subst educational
content of an adequate
education should that be inserted into
a uh you in the
new yeah so I I um I I think you may be
mixing two different things on on that I
I I think maybe we need to find out if
this is talking about library and media
centers and uh and what other resources
are being folded into this I I I think
we're having a hard time yeah I think
that's the threshold question on this
so okay the title may not be clear as to
here
okay well that gets us down to the next
one I have and I I'm only taking where I
you know had looked at some of this
stuff there may be other things that you
have but if the next one if we go down
jumps over quite a bit of
I handed out those sheets to you
about student teacher
ratios and the proposal I had was
to change educator to teacher
which is also supported when and under
educator it also talks about
teaching uh it says means a teacher or
there was another component of the old
of this this
one comes from any class size no let's
see yeah it was in the old class size
there was one other change that they did
make and that was the last part in the
interest of safety the maximum number of
students in laboratory classes in such
areas as science and Career Technical
education shall be determined by the
number of work stations and the size and
design of the area that's been
kept but it also goes on in no case
shall the number of students in
24 I have suggested that that be changed
to say in no case shall the number of
students in a laboratory class extend
exceed 24 unless permission to exceed is
board then the local school boards it's
on them uh they should be looking at
safety and the building and
it and I've also suggested student
teacher ratio rather than student
but I thought earlier we talked about um
the definition of educator and
I I don't know how you don't think we
have to change it to because we've
already done it right under the
definition
right so what's what's the impact of the
the change from size to ratio class size
well we've always been Staffing based
upon ratios
right
Staffing yeah you know employing
basically you're
funding it's been based upon that
formula you see in that sheet I handed
out to you that's the well the the
calculation of the base yeah yeah no no
that's that's correct but but that's
different than this this is class size
so this is what um what a school would
have to comply with to make sure that um
kindergarten through grades grade two 25
um and so I'm trying
to 20 students
so so for the the proposed rule is
titled ratios but then in it it has
class
size I guess I'm trying to figure out
whether using ratio yeah how how the how
the ratio
so so ju just looking at
kindergarten kindergart or looking at
the proposed A1 kindergarten through
grades 2 25 students or fewer per
educator so that would be a ratio of
fewer per
educator so if you
had
four sections of kindergart or four
sections of grade two let's say you
could have um two at 20 and two at
30 and you'd have that you'd achieve
yeah I'm just just testing I think
that's
that yeah yeah as opposed to the current
rule which would say 25 students or
fewer per educator you're talking about
size so that means that if you have four
sections of grade two um none of the
sections would be able to be more than
right doesn't the same apply under the
current
30617 because it is based as we've said
on a ratio that's not what not not not
current 30617 it says class
size right 25 students or fewer per
educator
right which
is as opposed to a ratio right but the
wording in kindergarten and grades 3
through five one and two is exactly the
same isn't it the wording the the
wording is the same but but but the
first part of one and two in the current
rule referred to class size 25 students
or fewer per educator in a class in the
in the new one in the proposed one 25
students or fewer per educator in the
ratio so that would apply to all grades
in a actually you could apply to the
entire block of grades into kindergarten
through grade two so if you had
um you know if you had um you know two
kindergartens two first grades and two
second grades uh you could have so you
know if if your you know kindergarten
counts were
you know say 15 you could have a a count
of say 30 or 35 in grade too as long as
you are over that over that BL over that
that that grade range um achieving a
ratio of 25 students or
fewer that I mean that's how I read that
so it's not limited to the class it's
limited to the but the way I read it
both are dealing with
ratios and both have the exact same
wording and that they shall stri strive
to achieve the class size of 20 or
however many um students or fewer per
educator so I I I think um you know I'm
not bothered by the fact that the title
of um the section is changed from class
size to educator ratios because it is
based on ratios well then then given
that why don't we go why don't we stick
with the original language and then add
um chair lad's suggestion to the end of
of C going unless approved by the local
you know unless um you know in you know
higher number in a in a lab is approved
board they do use ratio again though in
a the local school board shall establish
student and will change it to teacher
ratios that promote student but a and
the original is class size for
instructional purposes so they are
changing it to ratio which means you can
add up all the kids and grades
kindergarten through two and divide them
by the number of teachers and come out
with a different number than what they
really are in CL ratio instead of size
yeah but they shall strive to achieve
the class size of 20 students or fewer
per educator but that's aspirational
that's not that's not a request right
but it's still aspirational and
current yeah the the 20 number is
aspiration the 25 number in the current
rule is a hard maximum for the number of
students per per educator in a classroom
in the new rule it means averaged over
the entire uh group of of classrooms
kindergarten through grades two um just
like what what represent Cornell said
you add up all the kids and you divide
it by the number of teachers in those 10
classes rooms and it has to be 25 or
less but it doesn't mean that any
classroom couldn't necessarily have 40
it that's the difference between ratio
and and hard stop class
size but if you're talking about let's
say uh three sections of 60 students uh
do you think that the um administration
of the school is going to put um 40 in
one class and 10 in each of the other
two
classes yeah yeah I mean I'm not this is
this is a rule this um this why we have
rules you know
um that's why we have minimum standard
it's not that I think a principle is
going to going to do this but if we're
going to have a rule that that where
you're expecting that class sizes are
not going to be greater than 25 then
but class sizes change during the course
of the Year depending on students coming
and going as well so mid year or in uh
December um if three kids who are in um
section A
leave um do you have to rebalance then
um all the uh class
sizes I I actually I think that's a
great question and how is that
I mean we've got some Educators here in
the room that probably could answer
that you know the the issue of this
issue as a school principal for
years was always a tough one from the
standpoint that class and we had four at
each grade level in this particular
building I'm talking about but the
fluctuations in students went anywhere
from a 100 students per grade level mhm
to maybe 65 70 depending upon the year
mhm and so then you end up having to
make these
decisions are you going to have a
combination classroom now of A and B at
grade level grade one and two
um and you know it it really impacted
your instruction and your curriculum oh
yeah for you had have people that were
real good at being able to work
individually with students or had a good
handle on especially when you I always
found that really tough when I started
getting um in the Upper Elementary
grades the intermediate levels and above
when we were starting to have some
subjects that
were
pre we were using saxs and math we get
pre-algebra MH and and so it it's it's
it's a huge issue and you know you're
going to have a huge class piling in
after this one class goes through do you
do you can people or do you try to make
it work well I think what what what we
saw when I was on the board was um was
if you had say u a large um uh
enrollment in in grade two let's say
there was 100 kids and then in grade one
maybe there were 80 kids that um that
you had um you had you know uh four
sections and grades two and well say
five sections in grade two four sections
in in grade one and
then the following year you would you
would you would you know increase maybe
have an additional section in grade
three and have one less section in grade
two to correspond to the the popul the
enrollment moving through um but but I
hear what you're saying too about about
midyear changes people move in people
move out and if you're right at the
right at the limit um that could um
create some problems I don't remember
what I mean I'm sure we had these things
come to the board um uh I'm I'm I'm
actually sort of looking at Becky
because she was at a lot of these board
meetings and and I don't recall what
what we did if we if the board had the
authority to Grant the superintendent um
uh space there I I don't remember what
start in SEP with 25 students all
classes do liity
toate so I think that is why
mosts take the
number okay great no that that helps a
lot and I was a principal in a community
where we had a large Coast Guard
contingency and we had these folks
moving in at those weird weird times in
a school year and we could see six or
seven eight kids leave just like that
and and come in and we might have 15 new
ones coming in so you you have to have
some flexibility you strive to do these
things but
um you know that's why you know being a
teacher is so important you know that
you you know there are are some teachers
that can handle larger numbers others
cannot that's a given and because of
their experience and quote
wisdom
um and discipline all all that comes in
hand and as a principle you know where
where your strengths and weaknesses are
within the school I there's got to be
flexibility here that we're going to
give the school I don't I don't know if
that having a class size is a firm
boom
um unless there is some exception
size teacher education ratios I can't
imagine any Elementary principle loading
kindergarten what that would do
that it if it's it may not be
well depends on if your budget gets cut
10%
yeah well then it's on the school board
this I was coming from the standpoint I
want to make sure absolutely sure that
the person that's teaching that class is
a certified
teacher one so that's why I wanted to
use the student teacher ratio and change
it from educator to teacher and
duplicate what we did in that committee
report and how we're funding education
be
consistent um I wasn't looking at you
know I did look at class size and at one
point in time I even tried to change the
title when I was looking at this student
teacher classroom
ratios uh but then there's a lot of
people that are working in those
classrooms that aren't the primary
classroom teacher mhm that you got to
count to the music teacher the PE
teacher and etc
etc the
nurse so so
um in the um in in in both the current
rule class size in the proposed rule
ratio there's there's a there's a
paragraph B which is sort of a circuit
breaker um class size requirements may
be exceeded or ratios may be exceeded uh
study halls band course other types of
large group
instruction um so you know you've got a
high school teacher that that says Hey I
want to do a class on this and uh 40
kids sign up you know what Full Speed
Ahead so
I you're reading that for which grade
for high school right well I think
that's where you're going to see large
group instruct
lectures things like that Larry bford
used to say give me 100 kids that want
to take calculus and we'll teach it in
um so I think you've got that circuit
breaker that applies at the at the older
raade levels uh but for the uh the the
K what's the range the sort of K5 K2 and
five the class size thing works pretty
well and I like the explanation that
that principles are striving towards
that towards the recommended number and
that provides that flexibility I mean
you you'd have to see a u 25% increase
in your student enrollment to over a
budget well maybe um as in the uh
current
30617 uh class size for instructional
see on the on uh the class size side
30617 which is there and the what's
being proposed in 314 it says grades 3
through five then it goes on then over
here it says middle and Senior High
School does that include grades four
five that are down below can I go either
way with my you know I have a school
that's K through or you know up to grade
eight and the wing is fourth grade
through 8th grade is the Middle School
Wing how many kids do I have to have my
my classrooms in the fourth
grade can I have the ratio or am I going
to get the class size but I'm going to
choose to do the class size for grade
four and another guy down the road or
gal might say well I'm going to take the
Middle School ratio which is 30 m for
mhm yeah I I don't know I don't think
that I mean how's that done how's that
done today put that as a question yeah I
mean
yeah because we do we do provide
levels so does anybody there have any
help for us those those that are in you
know the middle school grades but also
considered grades at the elementary
which ratio do they go by or which class
that's
imagine yeah
yeah yeah
so you Beck you know hail middle school
and that is grades 4 through eight
separate building from K through three
down in Woodsville so grade four they
yeah do we need more discussion on this
one with them
doe as we did there there's going to be
a couple areas here which are going to
require this is one of the conflict
areas right here I I I think so too and
and and you know I think better
understanding why why they're why
they're suggesting moving from size to
ratio I mean what's what's the the the
rationale for making that change cuz I
you know seems like a lot of the
feedback we've got is you're changing
class size um we I would need to hear a
really really compelling reason to move
from class size to ratio and I'm I I'm
not hearing any around this table and I
think we sort of keep getting back to
the fact that that that you can the
flexibility that princip that building
principles need is inherent in the
strive to 20 you've got the flexibility
to get to 25 if you know you you see a
25% or yeah 25% increase in your
four classrooms
so and and again midd Senior High School
30 students or fewer per educator it
doesn't say per class per class size it
says Ed per
educator so does that mean that it could
be the teacher and the par professional
your well that's exactly why I wanted to
have a say teacher
ratio that's exactly why I was going
over there with that
one and the and the teacher referenc in
those statutes we re referenc for
defining
educator and there's good rationale
behind saying student teacher ratio
so let's let's
um I'll put the communication out with
them that we want to
discuss size to
ratio um and get the rationale for
it uh more can we all agree though on
one other thing that um that the last
wording in that last item there uh
regarding the Laboratories that the if
there's except that has to be approved
by the local school board I'm fine with
that yeah they're responsible for safety
and all that yeah I'd be okay okay we're
okay with that so that so we got talk
about class size and student ratio still
and also I think we talked about 30608
whether that's uh related directly to uh
libraries media centers or yeah y yeah
and I just checked in with Manchester
while we talking and they keep the ratio
or the class size K through 4 is 20 and
Manchester Manchester is what okay 20
okay K through 4 is 20 students per
class yeah and K through 12 is
25 and that's the way it is that's what
they I hear all the time from your
Senator that we're talking and 28 kids
in a
classroom no in
news so Mr chairman I'm hearing that uh
we'll need another meeting with the
Department staff yeah on the several
issues right um and um given that we
have another meeting at
1:00 could we
um maybe call it for this meeting and
schedule that I'd like to yes I think
it's wise but there's one other major
issue which is going to come up here and
that's the last portion
here um dealing
with the issue of academic
standards and Frameworks curriculum
Frameworks where are the academic
standards is my question question are
the Frameworks academic standards or are
the Frameworks built upon the academic
be I went and asked people across the
street regarding
this
and they're going to have to reference
these curriculum Frameworks which were
in place prior
to our changing a funding back in 20072
2008 and before we had the substantive
criteria for an adequate education that
was defined first time in Statute in
2008 as a result of the recommendation
that came out of that committee and the
bill which was introduced in the session
of
2007 so that's when adequacy came in
place and the ad the academic standards
are referencing those paragraph one of
RSA 193
e2a which are those 11 subject
areas so the academic standards
reference those but those didn't come
into being until
2008 so curriculum Frameworks were in
place well before that
um so were the Frameworks built upon
what academic
standards
I I I we were talking about this earlier
this morning um last week uh I think I
heard the commissioner refer
to the curriculum
Frameworks as as synonymous with
academic standards that that you could
interchange those those two terms but I
think on on further conversation with
with you um chair lad uh is that there
are two different things the Frameworks
actually
include uh a
um like how to build a curriculum um or
or a certain type of curriculum onto it
and include academic standards so uh
I'll be honest I'm I I don't know either
um still have I guess haven't found
where the academic standards are okay on
the bottom page three in that right hand
column we have about five or 10 minutes
here it says right down the bottom there
it says during the 2007 session HB
927 relative to the specific criteria in
substitute education program that
defines an adequate education was
written and signed in law identifying
that the curriculum framework shall
present the
goals skills competencies and knowledge
called for by the academic standards for
each area of
Education the goals reference in the
Frameworks are the academic standards
that now that's my assumption what I'm
hearing therefore Frameworks are used as
ghouls to guide classroom instruction
and assessments and to ensure that all
students learn the same core skills it
is then understood that through
reference the curriculum Frameworks are
an integral part to proposed 306 rules
process this is a huge
change because if you're going to
change Frameworks are you in impacting
so where where did this where did this
text that you just read come from I
wrote it okay but goals sometimes what
your goal is is all sometimes if you
look it up academic standards are a
goal well you Frameworks you yeah I mean
we need more about Frameworks yeah yeah
and you said HB 927 basically had the
the the um the goals referenced by the
Frameworks are the academic standards
no that's not from 9:27 what is in that
is the sentence
that
um the curriculum framework shall
present the goals
skills competencies and knowledge called
for by the academic standards for each
area of Education that you know they're
talking about paragraph
one the rest is your the rest is my
commentary okay and my thinking
but the the goals it says the goals
skills competencies and
knowledge are any one of those areas
that we just I talked about are those
called academic standards I don't think
competencies are I would say no uh
knowledge no skills no goals
possibly as part of the framework as
academic standards
okay they're part of the framework now
if if that's the interpretation now I
went over the research and I said okay
give me as much as you have on 97 what
is it HB 978 927 927 they did but then
the next question is when did curriculum
Frameworks come to be were they in
statute prior to that and what was the
rationale or the intent of curriculum
Frameworks to be built on academic
standards that they are academic
know I've never been able to find
academic standards written
Frameworks but that needs clarification
but they are referenced independent of
the
Frameworks academic standards they are
in
law they're rep they're called academic
Frameworks it says the
goals skipping all the other stuff
goals are called for by the academic
standards for each area of Education the
goal skills competencies
knowledge that's all that's in in the
that bill that was back in
2007 and now we've echoed that and put
it back in the
mhm but I don't I don't know if if you
have these academic standards separate
from and they align they direct what
you're going to do in your
curriculum your curriculum has you might
have a curriculum that's way different
than his curriculum in his school but
it's built around those academic
standards so the guidelines and the
Frameworks are sort of like that guide
that incorporate academic
standards but what are the academic
standards in there are they listed
somewhere
separately or or do they or is the guide
the academic
goal right and the academic standard
would also Drive assessment wouldn't it
yes not the curriculum right the stand
the academic standard drives assessment
yeah
hopefully yeah your instruction your
curriculum and your assessment all have
right so we have about three things we
got to ask them to come over and impart
discuss maybe we can get clarification
on it m so so is there a good time or a
B bad time there's all bad times to meet
now after November 5th is a better time
for
[Laughter]
me but
remember that Jael car meets the middle
of
November and anything that would be
these are conditionally or approved they
can change this approval process or the
deal we can do it if we do it prior to
time do it
after pardon me if we could do it I
agree
5th so then the department won't have an
opportunity do anything we'll be able to
get some work to jel
yeah well the department could still do
well they could at least get us the
information that that we wish they had
been here today to
answer well I didn't I didn't ask them
to attend today though and I'll honest
today
can you believe it or not I got a Civics
meeting on October 31st that starts at 2
afternoon that's great for the kids
coming to the house trick- or
so um do do we anybody have are are the
28th 29th and 30th all really sliced up
for you guys could we come
in if we had them here with specific
questions answer we might be able to get
possibility do we do it like fearly
early in the morning yeah
9:30 you got to change your haircut no
that I don't want to mess with I mess
with that I I'm out I'm in the
dogghouse I can change it so and and um
and Rick to be clear we're looking at um
at uh uh getting some clarification on 8
which is sort of like the questions
about library and media center let me on
eight yes eight on 12 which is class
size versus ratios why why are we making
the change and then um and then you know
what if what you know overlap and 456 to
Elementary versus middle yeah and then
uh 28 29 um where are the academic
standards what are the differences
between academic standards and
Frameworks
yeah and we might be able to get some
research from people across street on
the when curriculum Frameworks came into
being I think it would be good to get
some statutory yeah stuff on that too
that's a great
idea just if you read this uh that bill
927 you can just go up to you know in
the web and you can pick that up put
down 2007 you can
it specifies very clearly the minimum
Public School approval standards and
curriculum Frameworks there's no mention
standards okay so we have three
areas got
it if we is 9 10:00 too early for you
guys I can do
that it's early in it yeah okay
9:30 it's all right per me it's
fine that way we could get out of here
by 10 yeah
hopefully hopefully
no 9 to 11 maybe 10:30 yeah okay 9:00 so
we're going to do 1028
1029 Jen can you get that in the
calendar
okay we're all good with the definition
educator so we made some progress today
o00 you know what